I have a question, Dr. Conner.
Yep, yep.
Um, in your video on, um, I was looking at your coffee for coffee
animals and there's three different, um, pieces about, you know, the coffee
animals, how to do it, it lists EDTA, possibly be putting with your coffee
animal, if you have heavy metals, what is that?
So EDTA, DMSO here, I got to mute everybody while I'm answering.
Okay, because I'm getting feedback when I'm talking. So those are key lady
agents. So if a person has heavy metals or toxins or any
inner substance that you're trying to get out of your body, um,
so let's take a step back. How does, how do God make our body to get rid of bad things?
There's two major pathways. So you have your immune system to kill
living organisms. So biotoxins. So if I have a fungus, a mold, a bacteria, a virus,
something like that, uh, that's where my immune system kicks in to kill that thing.
But chemicals, toxicities, heavy metals, uh, pesticides, herbicides, those kind of things
go out through by detox pathways. So remember, your detox-packsable pathways are not
assisted by your immune system. Your immune system's purpose is only to kill things.
So the only way your body's gonna detox is through, um, the pathways that we talk about in all
the genetic information. So the glutathione and SOD and cannellace,
grab it on to superoxide ions and, and getting rid of peroxidite traits.
Um, large chemicals and heavy metals going through your PUN1 pathway in your cytochrome P450 pathway.
The problem is, is that if I'm exposed to, let's use mercury as an example, um, a larger amount
than those pathways can tolerate at any given time, then it circulates so that PUN1 pathway
in the cytochrome P450 pathway are in the liver. So, uh, let's say I'm exposed to a bunch of mercury
through a vaccine. It's circulating in my bloodstream and it goes through my liver so much of it
is gonna be taken out. It circulates again, goes around again, goes through my liver so much of it
will be taken out, goes around again, especially if I have cytochrome P450 pathway defects
and PUN1 pathway defects. It keeps circulating and then you're gonna be, you're gonna die, you can't
have those toxins in your blood. So what your body does, it shuts them to your fat cells.
So your fat cells, particularly the most vascular fat cells, that those are the ones that are around
your organs, um, are going to take the brunt of them. Your fat cells think of them as having the
spiritual gift of accommodation. They just invite everybody in. So these heavy metals, toxins,
poisons, and upsetting in your fat cells and they stay there and they could cause all sorts of problems.
So when you have heavy metal toxicities, then what we want to do is use chelation therapy.
So a chelator, that word chelate is simply a Latin or Greek word that means to grab on to.
So there are certain chelated agents, EDTA, DMSO, that are great. Those are would be considered strong
chelators. IP6, about a fight citrus pectin. Those are milder chelators, but they can be extremely
effective. My sinuses are killing me right now because I just started a program with
modified citrus pectin at IP6 that is pulling mercury out of my sinuses and my teeth.
All this probably what you probably asked the question many times, what's wrong with that guy?
He always tells me he's got a cold. Well, I never told you probably, but the years,
a number of years ago, I went to the dentist and my tooth was killing me at an office
face that we had at that time. We had a dentist right next door. So I ran in there, got an appointment,
got my tooth fixed, yay, the paid went away. About two, three days later, I got really sick and I got
sicker and sicker and sicker and sicker. There was a point, there was several days that I literally
thought I was going to die. If it wasn't for primatee mist at the time, I don't think they would sell
it anymore. I don't think I'd be here. My throat closed up on me. I couldn't figure out what was
going on with me. I'd never take medication. I took antibiotics, tried to figure out what was this
an infection. Took a long time. Stupid me to figure out that it was probably mercury from that
that removal of the cavity that my dentist did. So I called the dentist and said, hey,
do you have a record of the cavities that you removed on me? Oh, sure, let me pull your card.
She pulls the card. I said, what was what were they? Oh, it was tooth number, this one, a tooth number,
this one. Were they mercury fillings? Yeah, they were. They were all mercury fillings. Well, you'd
never used any mercury vacuum. You'd never used a rubber dam. You'd never used anything to protect me
from mercury toxicity. Oh, no, we'd ever have problems with that. And my answer was literally,
you'd never have problems that somebody just, somebody figures out. That's what the problem is.
So I've been dealing with mercury toxicity for a long time. Many times, quite really hard,
try to keylate it out. Many times just too busy to even think about my health and I just haven't
done it. So now I'm kind of at a kick again. I'm going to get this mercury out of my body. So my
sinuses are actually feel like I got to somebody's sticky with a with a ice pick right now for the
last few days. So but it's because it's pulling that mercury out. Now you can use EDTA or DMSO
in a coffee as well. So you can help pull that out as well. I typically don't recommend that. There's
better ways to keylate because you know, I've done suppository EDTA, which has been extremely
helpful. You have to be careful though, because I classify keylaters in three classes. EDTA and DMSO
are very strong keylaters. They're going to pull really hard. And you could have symptoms from them.
IP6, modified citrus pectin, those are moderate keylaters safe for everybody.
Though you might have symptoms like I'm having if you got a head full of mercury.
And then there's the keylaters that don't go past the gut wall, which are the different things that
you take just to grab stuff in the gut. I think I'm right off the top of my head right now.
It just so that you don't re-absorb things. So you just help keep them into the guts of that
you deposit them in the toilet. But the the negative of strong keylaters is that rule number one is you
can't use strong keylaters if you have any metal in your mouth. So if you have any mercury fillings
still in your mouth, you can't use DMSO and EDTA. I know there's doctors that do that, but my rule is
you don't do that because you'll be pulling stuff through your teeth into your body forever.
You have to get the mercury out of your out of your fillings first. So if you have mercury fillings,
those two are out. And then it might be better to start with a milder key later just so you don't
have symptoms. You could use modified citrus pectin in your coffee edema. That's another way to take it.
It's easy to take that orally and it really works well orally so that's why I don't do that.